hello and welcome to this video
is the opponent sorry
so um we got something
not sure that this has a clear
completely agreed upon name
probably something like the end time
nimzu indian
it has never indian flavors of bishop
before but white has not played the move
d4 yet
and this is generally believed to be a
favorable
change for white because you sometimes
can use that long
diagonal for example with ideas like b4
and bishop b2
black is taking a long time here
yeah that's that's a bit odd
honestly because you usually want to
play like d6 b6
put your pawns on dark squares and
have d6 e5 played so that the bishop on
b2 will be
somewhat blunted um
now i think i probably managed to play
b4 bishop b2 okay so
is he going to sacrifice a pawn now or
hm okay i will take if he
wants to okay so he's sacrificing a pawn
i don't quite believe it it's it's
possible that this is a bit of
compensation but
i have a hard time to believe it's
enough
b6 is a tempo
that cannot be enough quincy tomb
it just takes more time to gain another
tempo on the queen
so deform
for bishop d3
bishop b7 bishop d3
yeah the question is can i take on h7
maybe i can
no then okay bishop h7 king h8
doesn't quite work
but it also doesn't have to work i mean
just play a normal move bishop h7 king
h8 mcqueen doesn't have a good square to
go to queen b1 does rook take c1
we can check that later
and maybe e5 yeah
i tend to underestimate those kind of
yeah i mean he blundered a pawn
essentially that was not a
intended sacrifice and um
in those cases i tend to underestimate
the compensation when you know that okay
they just blundered it and
make things up um now
as they go along but sometimes it's it's
a little bit
yeah this it happens so
bishop b5
it's also possible to simply castle
maybe just castle come on
he takes d4 i just take e takes
i need the pawn on d4 to restrict the
knight on d7
bishop b5 was maybe good
and i'm really behind in development and
i want to
get out of the center
not like he has anything great here i
think
um bishop b5
what's going on here where is there an
ingenious idea
that i don't see
just put himself into a pin
okay so takes here then b5 huh
okay
so bishop takes b5a takes queen takes
queen check scientific
nice he has a bit of compensation there
i wonder if it's better just to play
queen b3 queen d7 knight takes e5
no actually this
and e4 e4
is there some brilliant tactic for
knight f4 maybe
okay come on take it
he wants to play a knight discovery and
bishop takes f3
i have to have really screwed up this
game
i mean
it should be over long ago long ago
and i did not manage to put this away
that's absolutely remarkable
i just lost some time that was such a
weird game
so yeah he he gave me this pawn here
which
hmm can it cannot be a correct sacrifice
but the way i played it it was kind of
interesting again so
this this so i think i shouldn't take
maybe because after king h i don't have
a good square
if i go here my bishop gets cut off
and queen b1 there's at least rook takes
c1 but f5 seems to be even stronger
i saw this which is enough to
yeah um not play it so
queen a4 e5
i castled rookie 8
bishop b5 a6
oh i can take c8 just grab everything
and that's true
actually i didn't see that
yeah i mean this is a lot of material
right i have two
bishops and a rook for the queen which
is uh
more than enough but okay this is not a
mistake but i should probably really
take with the knight
i just take with the knight
i thought it could be good to take away
squares from this knight but it is not
good
clear and now
yeah i kind of have to play e4 i mean
the the computer
agrees but this is of course nothing
in comparison to what i had so here
i just have a smallish advantage a 0.1
yeah coming from plus whatever it was a
lot
yeah i'm just not a good way to convert
a large advantage
okay guys thanks for watching